have you ever watched Batman family do
you ever watch it back yeah how old were
you when you started I was 10 I was 10
years old okay yeah the actual set was
awesome everyone was like really
incredible still like a strange place
for like a kid to grow up and like have
your like awkward years blasted so like
if I ever want to like hate watch myself
like I'll go back but like the weird
thing is going back there were like
certain jokes I didn't get at the time
they're just now registering there was a
whole episode we did where
um the all the the three young Dunphy is
walking on their parents having sex and
I didn't really know what sex was at the
time of course not I was 10 years old
and so I just bullshitted my way through
the entire episode
um I remember there was a joke that my
character says whatever they were doing
it looked like Dad was winning and I
didn't I didn't understand what that was
in reference to I just knew that if you
said it like it was a dirty thing that
like it would get a laugh out of people
that's my